as violence fled in Leicester inside
this car was a young Hindu man
he'd become the target of a group of
angry Muslims you tried to run over and
over the false rumor that he tried to
drive into them had spread through the
crowd as they went to drag him out the
car a man stepped in and ordered them to
let him go
that man was Muslim activist Madrid
Freeman the Hindu he helped was Ram
keshwala
Ram needed stitches after his head was
slashed
he's here to thank the man from the
opposite side who came to his defense
you saved my life
coming day because of that I'm still
here
maybe I would have I would have be here
I wouldn't be here right now it was just
me him everything was happening so fast
and other people were trying to come and
I was just shouting that stop it's done
it's done now but I don't think there
was anyone that was physically stopping
it because the situation so hostile
anything anyone could get
several people were hurt that night as
hostility spilled onto the streets
Bilal was injured and in hospital at the
same time as RAM but they haven't met
until now Bilal is a Muslim from
opposite sides they want peace restored
in their City we need to find the root
Force that's the first thing we need to
find out that who are these youngsters
are coming must stop and instigating
things how do we control the youth who
want to take revenge I think they should
like speak to each other like a all
these people like speak with a
communities and talked about what's
happening what's wrong what's going on
they say on both sides misinformation
keeps fueling tensions this tweet went
viral wrongly accusing Ram of supporting
the RSS a far-right Hindu nationalist
organization
now right now I feel like still I don't
feel like safe I might get attacked by
people because some people don't know
I'm innocent because I didn't do nothing
at the moment everyone's looking over
their shoulders everybody's losing
there's no winners on that they do agree
and when finding common ground isn't
easy this is surely a start Becky
Johnson Sky News Leicester